Триста тисяч військових, понад тисяча літаків, гелікоптерів,
до36 тисяч танків, бронетранспортерів та іншої техніки -
російські військові називають навчання "Схід-2018" найбільшими з часів СРСР.
Маневри на сході Росії, як правило, завжди масштабніші, зазначають німецькі експерти.
Адже їх не стосується Віденський документ, який обмежує розмах навчань у європейській частині РФ
Втім, на їхню думку, це не єдина причина.
Якщо ми подивимося на те, які військові частини беруть участь у навчаннях,
то стає зрозуміло, що Росія тренує свої війська на випадок  глобальної війни,
не виключаючи застосування ядерного потенціалу країни, -
адже у маневрах беруть участь Північний та Тихоокеанський флот ВМФ,
оснащені атомною зброєю.
Навчання "Схід-2018" відбуваються на Далекому Сході,
і хоча до України - тисячі кілометрів, брюссельські оглядачі радять Києву не розслаблятися.
Немає жодних ознак завершення воєнного конфлікту України й Росії.
Радше навпаки - ми бачимо складнішу ситуацію із безпекою,
особливо довкола Азовського моря.
Україна, очевидно, має продовжувати інвестувати у свою безпеку та удосконалення озброєння,
оскільки військовий тиск з боку Росії навряд чи зникне.
Серед особливостей навчань "Схід-2018" - те, що у них беруть участь китайські військові.
Хоча, порівняно з російським контингентом, їх на маневрах набагато менше:
близько 3000 осіб, плюс літаки та гелікоптери.
Особливість цих тренувань полягає в тому, що Китай запросили брати участь
не лише в антитерористичних навчаннях з поліцією,
але і у стратегічних військових вправах - цього китайці прагнули вже давно.
З 2003 року Росія та Китай провели разом близько тридцяти військових навчань.
За словами Ґресселя, шляхи розвитку Пекіна і Москви зводять їх все ближче один до одного
у військовій та політичній галузях.
Росія розуміє безпеку передусім як збереження чинного політичного режиму,
тому Захід та США - це вороги,
оскільки Москва розглядає саму модель західних демократій як загрозу для себе.
А Китай, попри те, що межує з Росією і має більшу армію,
не сприймається як загроза для режиму.
Загалом же, переконані німецькі аналітики,
широкомасштабні навчання "Схід-2018" - це очікуваний сигнал з Москви у бік США та НАТО.